today's topic is locking now a lot of
people been asking us haven't preached
why don't you guys flawed why don't you
guys make different types of content and
there's I think a variety of reasons why
we don't do it I think the biggest
things that mean preach a very peculiar
about what kind of content we want to
put out there I was sorry
yeah where's your wife can we see her
why did you ever struggle with that how
much you want to share your personal
life and like how much is too much too
much is more of the information I'm
giving YouTube right now if I didn't
give it to you then that's so much okay
let's just say clear line you know yeah
what is that one if it's more than what
I'm giving you right now okay
that's too much okay you see how I
didn't give you more information I just
exactly interviewed George st. Pierre
was giving and you were grilling him oh
yeah what is her girlfriend do you have
someone and this and that and he's like
listen I'm a fighter
that's what I do that's it yeah why
don't you want to disclose that I'm like
because the person that is what this is
always an argument what do you say yeah
but you're a public figure so all you
see everything that's about you is now
public okay I don't but okay what is
about me is published but the person
that I'm with then choose that life I
did so in order to respect that I
disagree with that it's not because
people produce art that you love and
that you enjoy that you and necessarily
are entitled to everything
nor should I think it nor do I think
it's healthy for you to be so invested
in that you're like wow Oprah's marriage
is going is irrelevant it's not in your
business right Ellis unless she's
someone who died wickets against
cheating and then she turns out to me
mode alter or so ELISA has some direct
correlation with her work you have no
right to demand or to think that you
deserve this kind of information and
when you do you create a market for
things like bad tabloids and bad
newspapers who we are very invasive in
people's lives I almost think that
people care a little bit too much of
what's going on other people's lives
because their lives are inadequate and I
think it's unhealthy
some people voluntarily do it because
they like the isolation they like the
fact that people are bested but no
problems logging is it's supposed to be
a glimpse into our lives
it's supposed to be a glimpse into oh
you know our day to day but the
realities are day to day and most
people's day to day is not that
interesting it's just not you know like
I enjoy but I take great joy in things
that I know would never be interesting
on camera my short conversations with my
friends when we're saying down together
that brings me tremendous amount of joy
me just being able to sleep in bed
brings me a tremendous amount of joy and
I just want to be able to enjoy those
things and I don't think that would be
interesting to you but if I want to
portray a life online I would have to
start doing stuff that's outside the
normal that's why you see vloggers
constantly thinking about new content to
turn out they start to engage in
activities not because they're actually
genuinely interested but they think it
would make for good content do you see
how crazy that is we are changing yes
okay what I gotta create now I got a
piece of [ __ ] guess what no parachute
wine when we land let's have a camera
right there so when I turn it to pancake
batter
it'll get millions calm down bro
why do you think that logan paul video
what happen most sensible people he
would know that it's a bad idea to go to
force and film in person his fans didn't
think there was anything wrong with it
and he didn't think anything wrong with
it because he was so busy trying to turn
out content that that was his only
concern what's the most shocking
with what everything millions of use and
afterwards he apologized for it and all
that stuff but you recognize that your
soul was in that cycle and another
youtuber named Casey nice that someone
who's famous for vlogging he burnt out
you know cuz he was so busy documenting
his family in his life every day he was
consistently doing at a high level that
has it took a toll on his relationships
I mean it affected it tremendously and I
think that the working so much was only
a small part of it I think a bigger part
of it was the fact that you know my
family was such a big part of the vlog
for so long
like when my older daughter now turned
one or like 11 months we stopped putting
her in any videos in any social media
it's like the first time when she turned
one was when the vlog was like four or
five months old and I realized that like
whoa there's an audience here people are
watching this I don't want to put my
kids out there in this capacity anymore
I stopped putting them out there but
even so that aside you know my
relationship with my wife was a big part
of the narrative my relationship with my
kids as far as me being a father was a
big part of it yeah and I think the
social implications of that were as
impactful if not more than the sheer
hours I was working and the implications
of that were things like if Candace and
I weren't in a good place in our
marriage there's no way she was gonna
like be chipper when I pointed a camera
at her and by chipper I mean willing in
any capacity I mean anything but her
putting her hand over the lens saying
turn that [ __ ] thing off
so I you know I used to like avoid
fights with her avoid arguments with her
I very very deliberately used to quell
any disagreements we'd have because I
needed her for content yeah so she would
not have conversations with the person
that he was married to so that he can
make content for the public and that's
what I mean no matter how you want to
spin it it's like we did right and when
you dance and you're on your room or in
a cypher it feels different than you
know just just that just dancing it by
yourself at us you know different
dancing disciple feels different yeah
even so imagine dancing by yourself but
there's a camera pointed at you yeah the
idea of being observed affects the
subject
understand like me I like to cook but
what I could for other people it feels
different what I'm cooking about myself
you know I'll take cinema not put pasta
I'll put my cinnamon on our pasta great
I'm happy I'd have to think about it
right we'll put cinnamon on your pastor
see he's already affecting me right he's
judging you right now everybody's
judging you right now that's whole point
cinnamon in your past in your past Jean
and this wild luck mr. Kutz kid whatever
your weirdness is you don't want that
influence of the outside world on what
you're doing when I'm talking with my
friends it would not be the same
experience if I had a camera on right
you want somebody and she goes to her
[Music]
okay stop yeah because your friends are
only getting the best certain moments I
think you just got to be present for you
know I don't want you to be vlogging
during your wedding ceremony I don't
want you to be vlogging when you're
having a heart-to-heart with your child
you know like don't involve everyone in
some moments don't need to be documented
I guess that's really what it comes down
to for me I think we're sacrificing real
experiences for likes we're sacrificing
real moments and Inter
actions with their loved ones for
adulation on the internet and it's a
heavy price that we're paying we're
ruining those relationships for the sake
of other people and it's great because
and also I think it also leads other
people to believe that life can be lived
that way people watching you or like oh
there's people that live life's like
that now I'm like no no that [ __ ] is
just an Instagram feed it's not because
I work okay so today no that's not it's
Facebook it's not a Danny oh yeah the
diary there is milk start a diary it's
not dairy either you can't stand there
it makes me poop anyways yeah diaries do
the same for your ideas but it was to
gossip we're definitely getting flanked
once we said poop it was over you - not
really
oh yes this enlists mom so what happens
like why can't I find any pictures of
your mom
you know I want to tell you something
real [ __ ] I constantly struggle with
sharing personal parts of my life and
putting them online because of your boy
I know I know I know because I talked
about her once of your mom doesn't that
one of the worst feelings when you share
something that you felt like you
should've kept yourself and this person
always has that you felt like you you
almost sullied yourself yeah it's like
you were you were vulnerable with
somebody that didn't deserve it they
always have that so when I write posting
[ __ ] is about me in vacation yeah
vacation is full of being present and
experience is like so digital everything
there's nothing worse than I was hanging
out with friends and one of us is always
I chose to get pictures here we go chill
out with them pictures I know I want to
see your opinions because we're curious
about what yes I'm told I'm gonna do it
no leave your comments below
two good videos
[Music]